hello everybody and welcome to I don't
even know what part this is I'm just
gonna I my brain is tasked to capacity
trying to get these puzzles done so I'm
just gonna stop saying the parts and
embarrassing to myself when I get them
wrong oh man cuz every time I do get
them wrong I have to get out of the game
check the footage make sure I'm not an
idiot which I which I'm not of course no
one likes my blood blood voice I don't
think let's say move that box ah what
the hell did I fall in water what the
hell oh I was messed up my huge muscles
weighed me down straight to the bottom
alright box jumping lead or mega awesome
I can make that oh yeah fine fine
get box get stuck yeah we could go no
falling ladder right leap box jumping
one two five seventeen ops victory flash
yeah oh oh I just put a battery i ah i
shorted out my flashlight well I was
dumb of me fine whatever
ah Road Oh
dead end phenomenal oh I see yeah okay
yeah boxes come here boxes
oh there there we go all right up and
out oh so great
uh ooh unisex bathroom what's in here
batteries just what I needed clothes
ticket for small environments I'm
getting smart fleshy fleshy oh look at
myself how handsome I am can you see a
broken mirror with my handsome is not my
ugliness we get TV books other
individuals binder looks important
maybe know what's under the bed he'll oh
then I'll take a little now oh I figured
out these are save points I think that's
why there you send something about
copies being dumped in Oh yep alright a
touchy oh yeah I can move that Oh what
do we got little yeah what's that
what are we got here it's an onion oh oh
it's a puzzle okay I got it
Oh ping oh so smart the picture
okay
still nothing in here
that is a portal for monsters to just
come pouring out so I'm gonna block this
up probably why I can move this thing
be smart come on oh come on little more
all right I guess it doesn't help
considering boobs oh whatever
Oh what what what the help
seems to be working so open up computer
ah god I gotta
this micromanaging me to the limit
okay the powers on what do you want from
me TVD work a fight No there oh yeah
there we go oh yeah I love to check oh
wow why even bother video chat I suppose
I'm flattered hi I'm Annabel uh-huh
I suppose I'll be your guide for the day
oh shut up hello can you hear me yep
I think the transmissions only one way a
webcam pose silly face if you can hear
me you know very attractive yes I am
there's some things you need to know
oh really baby
that is not John Tucker we released a
virus wiped us out
yeah three weeks ago we tried to get out
through the minds but it didn't work the
way we'd plan I just came in through the
minds I ran and when I stopped I was on
my own
I'll save you baby another symptom it's
deja vu Oh Oh like a thing I have my
daddy or John's daddy no matter his
vitals last registered in the library
many members of the organisation have
access I'm still seeing a few life signs
in the residential quarter yes you need
to find a survivor and get through into
the library look out for our medical guy
Richard M&S he was acting strangely when
I last saw him yeah he's a monster what
else don't you know let's see
watch out for signs of infection
infection oh did you say something
look the seasons we know about our
paranoia and aural Distortion oh and
another symptom is DejaVu
this is ridiculous Wow
John I'm toughen you up so you don't get
infected on the virus and I'll get some
doors open for you maybe now we can
shoot the ship right she seems awfully
calm for being trapped here for however
long they have been what five weeks uh
all right what was her name Emma Belle
she sounds hot yeah what how I just put
batteries in it oh it's such crap fine
I'll put batteries in it but I'm using
my clothes stick Oh infected I'd skipped
a beat when I heard that word in
association with me still it seemed like
just one more reason to find my father
hearing a friend either all right Oh a
hallway but there's monsters not Billy
come on get up dekosky Randy
monkey monkey you call me monkey I call
you monkey
Oh Oh give me control of myself
Oh baloney Oh Oh monkey you are so so uh
I'm not even good Gracie with monkey I
need a mortgage rating name oh god I
hate you so much oh I hate you so much
oh I hate you so much
Oh finally God
that was annoying good get out here are
you gay made that was this get them I'm
going to smash it with mother oh yeah oh
yeah give me that right the game makers
wanted to find a more annoying voice to
pester with me throughout the game they
couldn't have done a better job a plus
batteries oh you all right what's in
here who's there Oh nobody yeah they
were scared where the heck am I
where the heck am I I heard that h8
double of hockey sticks was that a code
306 one ok 306 one
I remember ah nothing goodness gracious
gravy
alright this is number one I'll just
start through go number two three four
five six seven eight what's a trick
there by say that makes no sense
whatever canteen Oh Jam door oh this
ridiculous ridiculous
all right par 3 is right here oh thank
you
Savage infected terrified and now I was
hearing voices
yep just up alrighty
other we got Oh books manuals stuff like
that
alright computer Oh card slot ok so I
could set up oh I get it
I need a card to transfer it we got here
uh-huh yeah nope uh-huh you like the
fuse is the card is located two feet
from the place it's supposed to be get
open boot Network crunch um completely
fried how about this one gimme gimme
giving it gimme ah yeah that looks fried
see how about this one looks fried in
her face looks good there
moderately okay maybe maybe maybe maybe
come here good oh yeah get in there
ah shut up you look good at me uh get
Obed so we got here uh-huh
lats whole power yeah you're probably
running on power that I turned on in the
last game all right I got a posit but
thank you so much for watching I will
see you next time in let's play penumbra
the Black Plague bye bye